last time we said we can't predict
exactly what will happen when we measure
a quantum system but the born rule tells
us how likely the possible outcomes are
in this video I'll first teach you the
easy version of this rule that works for
most simple cases and will work for all
the stuff we'll do in the main quantum
videos then if you feel like it you can
stick around for the proper rule as well
so as usual we have our wave function in
a superposition of all possibilities if
I measure it will collapse to just one
of these to find the probability that it
will collapse to this state all I have
to do is take this coefficient and
square it that's all so if I had a
superposition like this then the
probability that the cat is alive is 1/2
and is dead is also 1/2 this version of
the born rule is very easy the actual
rule is only slightly more complex in
that it's a little bit more involved
but it isn't hard at all I'll explain
that now if you're interested you won't
need it for my main quantum videos but
you will need it for any of the optional
videos I make on the maps of quantum
mechanics so it's up to you skip to the
next video if you like previously we
looked at the case where these
coefficients are real numbers the kind
of numbers were all used to using but
actually in quantum mechanics were
allowed to use a more general type of
number called complex numbers I think
the most useful way to think of complex
numbers for quantum mechanics is to see
them as arrows first real numbers are
kind of like arrows to pointing this way
or that way if they're negative the
length is just the absolute value of the
number complex numbers generalize real
numbers because they're like arrows that
are allowed to point in any direction so
the coefficients of the wave function
are like little arrows of different
lengths if they're all real the arrows
point left or right if they're complex
then they can point in any direction but
the born rule is the same for both cases
if you want the probabilities of this
state look at the arrow in front of it
and find its length
weird in real numbers this is exactly
the same as squaring the number let's
look at this example if you have this
coefficient in front of the state its
length is root three on four and so it's
probability is three on four but what if
I rotated this arrow so that it's not
real anymore the length is still the
same so the probability stays the same
you might be wondering then what's the
point of using complex numbers well it
actually doesn't matter at all to the
Vaughan rule but it really matters for
what we're looking at in the next couple
of videos and so these two states are
actually very different physically so
that's the bond rule but drawing little
arrows with exactly the right length and
angle is really tedious so in case you
haven't seen it before
I'll introduce you to the more standard
notation for complex numbers if we have
an arrow like this then we call this
direction the real direction and that
direction the imaginary one then we want
to know how far we need to go each way
to get to the end of the arrow in this
case it's d units in the real direction
and in units in the imaginary one which
we can then write as d plus e i where i
represents one unit in the imaginary
direction so instead of drawing the
arrow we can just write down this and
here are some other examples of it this
is really useful because now we can
write wave functions more compactly for
example this wave function
and now it's your favorite time of the
video homework time by the way I'll type
the questions up in the description as
well first a math one if I have a
complex number a + bi use Pythagoras's
rule to find the length of it so what's
the probability of a state with this
coefficient then of course an
interpretations question many people
have found the use of complex numbers in
the wavefunction very significant saying
that this shows that the wavefunction
can't actually be real then in other
words it can't be a real physical object
if so what kind of interpretations of
the wavefunction would that rule out but
also what do you think of this
conclusion that something described by
complex numbers couldn't actually
represent physical reality are people
taking the word imaginary to literally
leave answers in the comments thanks a
lot for watching I realize that this
probably wasn't the easiest youtube
video you could have been watching today
so I really appreciate the effort